ouais si jamel debbouze
j'ai mal aux assauts beaucoup internet
je comprend un petit peu ses
applaudissements et cet accueil par ce
que j'ai lu cette semaine dans le figaro
entreprises que vous étiez l'acteur le
mieux payé de france devant gérard
depardieu je les lui aussi j'étais très
déçu par ce qui a été
ce qui a été marqué parce que c'est
complètement faux j'ai touché le triple
salve énerve que ce soit par offrandes
de messes qui m'a amusé le plus c'est la
manière dont ça a été présenté son
journal de france 2 parce qu'il disait à
la grande chaufferie général vous
qu'elle veut que vivent de part des
années que non oui oui c'est non mais
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça amusant ça
nous fait plus de deux millions d'euros
c'est beaucoup
bonjour tu avais combien de jours le
tournage six mois de tournage le mans
mais en même temps j'avais aucun
problème quand je touchais 3700 francs
contre emploi solidarité et j'ai aucun
problème à toucher autant qui valait 1
autant d'argent aujourd'hui financier du
rmb lisf sans problème je le répète je
suis persuadé mais jamel en plus ça part
vite l'argent il y en ait plus j'en ai
plus la passe avon frères moment ma
cousine d'audincourt mon frère de gaza
et voisines du square le genre a fini
bien plus personne tu te reste combien
sur les 2 millions là mais je dois me
restait 700 euros elle m'a dit oui pour
tout ça va vite et par les impôts t'as
rien non non ça c'est pas quand je me
sens jamais plus d'un mois je les perds
est sûre si cette pige djamel alors vous
venez de cannes là où vous êtes une star
absolue d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans paris
match que vous étiez avec les plus
grandes stars du festival qui apprécie
beaucoup votre pas vrai j'étais à des
amis de la weed
j'étais avec gt avec charles âgé tient
avec abd el kader aoun
j'étais avec qui avait d'autres on et
j'étais qu'avec des cailleras 17,8
savait que je passais tous les temps
serait alors un parc à loups passé
beaucoup de temps au maroc beaucoup de
temps à marrakech vous avez une maison
que jamais et où vous avez monté des
studios de cinéma on
ouais ouais on les a pas encore ça fait
monter puisqu'on n'a pas encore on n'est
pas encore arrivé dans la phase où les
studios sont en construction mais on y
arrive on y arrive très vite et j'espère
du charlain que dc dc le prochain
festival du cinéma à marrakech au puisse
poser la première pierre
ah ouais ouais j'ai été super show pré
en tournant astérix de voir que je
n'avais pas d'à priori mais je ne
m'attendais pas à ce que les marocains
connaissent aussi bien le cinéma j'étais
vraiment surpris et et de voir un
premier assistant parlait quatre langues
différentes gérer quatre mille personnes
je me suis dit mais j'ai rarement vu ça
mais qui parle français anglais arabe
dans la même phrase ça donne à m
mais vous voulez mais samassa massama je
me suis aperçu je le savais déjà mois
mais le maroc s'est pas car c'est pas
qu'une terre sera qu'un paysage c'est
aussi des gens tu vois ce que dira
connaissent bien leur caf
donc ça me paraissait évident et logique
de montée des studios c'est une façon en
plus de faire du business et d'aider les
gens qui vivent là bas c'est vraiment
pas pour faire du business data studio
finalement ça rapporte pas tant d'argent
que ça coûte d'abord beaucoup au départ
mais moi ma démarche première c'est
vraiment d'essayer d'amener de faire en
sorte que les gens de mon pays puisse
travailler dans les conditions les mieux
possible les plus normal puisque on
monte d'abord avant de monter les
studios un centre national de
l'audiovisuel
ah ouais pour former les gens aux
premiers métiers du cinéma et et la
démarche allait purement professionnel
d'un moins avant d'être financière jamel
debbouze dont une au maroc à casablanca
le vendredi 16 mai cinq attentats
suicide ont fait 48 victimes majorité de
marocains plus trois français deux
espagnols un italien pour en parler avec
nous j'appelle samira sitail
samira bonsoir donc vous êtes directrice
de l'information de la chaîne marocaine
2m
merci d'être avec nous djamel au maroc
j'imagine que c'est une star comme en
france qua non à wind est aussi connue
et même beaucoup plus cogner je pense un
rock ici puisque jamais c'est la
réussite
jamel c'est un symbole jamais c'est pas
uniquement la banlieue qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il soit salué voir décrit
aussi par d'autres parce qu'ils touchent
le plus beau salaire de chambre si
jamais c'est patricia au maroc gmail
s'effrite à la fois et c'est une
mégastar bagel bagel maintenant j'ai
amené mon avocat eut donc en plein
milieu des festivités organisées à
l'occasion la naissance le 8 mai du
premier fils de mohammed vi le roi du
maroc et deux jours après l'aïd al
mawlid la fête de la naissance du
prophète
cinq attentats à la bombe ou à la
voiture piégée visant essentiellement
des restaurants des hôtels fréquentés
par des étrangers ou lié à la communauté
juive ont lieu à casablanca
li membre des commandos kamikaze était
d'origine marocaine
il ferait partie d'un groupe islamiste
appelait le droit chemin
implanté dans la banlieue de casablanca
est rattachée plus ou moins à al qaïda
alors vous qui êtes direct les
informations de dunes important de
chaînes marocaines
que savez vous sur les coupables de
cette opération
d'abord ils sont tous marocains ce n'est
pas uniquement les huit en fait on a
identifié au jour d'aujourd'hui huit
cadavres sur les treize kamikazes qui se
sont donné la mort sur les différents
sites que vous avez décrit jeudi rossi
oui on a visé les symboles
on a visé des symboles qui font
qu'aujourd'hui le maroc est l'antithèse
la plus complète de ce que les radicaux
les intégristes défendent comme modèle
de société
nous leur faisons tous les jours la
démonstration de ce que le maroc peut
être un pays musulman profondément
attaché à ses racines profondément
musulman tout en étant un pays arabe
berbère juifs
d'une certaine manière puisque cette
religion fait partie de l'histoire du
maroc
donc ces marocains qui sont touchés
lorsqu'on pose une bombe devant
l'alliance juive c'est les marocains qui
sont touchés c'est pas les juifs les
musulmans c'est d'abord cela est un juif
persécuté dans ce pays c'est quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose de
nouveau pour nous comme le sont ces
attentats imaginez qu'une ville paisible
se réveille un matin dans l'horreur la
plus absolue avec j'ai pas une ré cela
aux téléspectateurs mais c'est vraiment
le loreur et moi j'ai eu un fils mais
tout ça j'ai eu à voir tout cela et j'ai
eu à faire des choix de ne pas montrer
le visage une tête un gamin qui dort
encore et qui va s'éveiller avec les
images peut-être de son père
la tête coupée à la une de notre journal
j'ai refusé cela j'ai voulu respecter
cela et je crois que tous les marocains
quelque part sont un peu comme moi
aujourd'hui ils ont cette attitude à la
fois de surprise à la fois de révolte de
colère et en même temps et c'est ça
peut-être si j'osais dire à toute chose
malheur est bon que nous retiendrons de
ce 16 mai qui était le jour de mon
anniversaire
nous retiendrons que nous sommes plus
forts et que notre modèle est le bon et
aussi que cette guerre antiterroriste
menée à l'échelle mondiale dans un
désordre absolu depuis 18 mois nous en
payons nous les marocains aujourd'hui
les pots cassés et que c'est un échec
absolu
qu'est ce qui est important de dire
c'est que ça arrive au moment où ou au
maroc progresse vers une vraie
démocratie où coup on commença à
s'inscrire vers le ce qui m'a le plus
étonné c'est que vraiment cessé
j'ai le sentiment que mon pays mon pays
a été touché au coeur et est un traître
presque parce que j'ai j'ai j'avais le
sentiment qu'on paye progressait 6xl que
ça que ça se développait qu'on allait
coller ouais qu'on allait vers une vraie
ouverture sais pas comment expliquer mes
jeux
gt gt ou très bon pour non pas parce que
j'ai jamais connu ça au maroc j'ai
jamais vu ma mère dans cet état là
j'avais mon grand père n'a jamais eu ma
famille était là et je me suis aperçu
que partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui on est on est on est plus à
l'abri nulle part il ya un bus mémoire
sont les routes
il ya a été touché new york a été touché
en plein coeur paris pareil à vitrolles
ya catherine mégret
on est à l'abri nulle part donc
franchement aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment qu'il faut continuer à vivre
sa vie comme on l'entend et comme on dit
dans ma cité knicks à mr le maire
enfin ils sont quand même espérer que
c'est pas ces événements dramatiques qui
vont faire changer le maroc est bien au
contraire vous savez nous sommes à la
veille d'une très grosse manifestation
dans les rues de gaza
tout le monde descend demain tout le
maroc qui est dehors
demain juifs musulmans chrétiens vivant
dans ce pays puisque on en parle et
qu'il s'agit bien de cela nous défendons
cela c'est une partie de notre identité
nous combattrons l'intégrisme et si nous
n'étions pas conscient depuis un an
parce que c'est vrai on nous a dit il ya
des cellules dormantes
attention quand on a parlé salue avec
son appareil de cellules dormantes
il ya beaucoup d'intellectuels et
certains journaux qu'on dit c'est une
manoeuvre du pouvoir en fait c'est
existe pas tout ça c'est pour aller vers
le plus sécuritaire et en fait c'était
vrai c'était vrai et depuis le 16 mai je
peux vous garantir que cette presse là
où ces intellectuels là où ces gauchos
kalia qui hante la capitale économique
et rabat et qui ne finalement ne
connaissent pas très bien le maroc et
bien je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
sont très mal à l'aise et qu'aujourd'hui
il s'agit pour nous de protéger ce que
nous sommes c'est notre patrimoine c'est
ce que nous sommes et le marché le plus
important c'est pour le maroc c'est la
france 55 % du flux touristique au maroc
c'est le marché français et au contraire
et c'est ça qui est extraordinaire et
c'est pour ça que je suis heureuse
d'être là en france et sur ce plateau de
télévision
parce que les français ont dit non avec
les marocains ce terrorisme en disant
vas nous maintenant on
réservations dans les maintient le maroc
le maroc c'est aussi un peu chez nous
voilà
et vice versa les génériques on avait
compris les réactions mohamed 6 s'est
rendu évidemment sur les lieux du drame
alors moi mais si c'est le commandeur
des croyants ça veut dire qu il est
commandeur de tous les croyants c'est à
dire les juifs et chrétiens les
musulmans les trois religions les droits
renault il est bien sûr musulman est la
religion majoritaire au maroc et l'islam
mais il est le protecteur comme le fut
d'ailleurs son grand-père et sa la
communauté juive sépharade shass et et
j'aurais pu en éminent acclamé de la
colombie le chili a dit rooney 5 vous
nous livrer les juifs pour qu'il puisse
élire et aux allemands
il a dit je ne voulais livrerait pas
s'ils sont sous ma protection lorsque
d'espagne on les a chassés réprimer ils
sont venus au maroc ils vivent et si je
répète je ne sais pas si je les exprime
bien c'est bien comprend entre le fait
est que c'est ça qu'on veut toucher et
ce n'est pas à nous uniquement de le
défendre nous du maroc nous pays arabe
musulman
revendiquant cette identité musulmane
tout en projetant de comme n'importe
quel citoyen de ce monde aujourd'hui
alors moi médecis est en train de
démocratiser le maroc met effectivement
en plus de liberté c'est plus de liberté
pour les idées toutes les idées même les
idées islamistes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui au maroc il ya des
journaux quand même très radicaux qui
paraissent aujourd'hui et depuis le 16
mai les marocains je crois qu'ils se
sont rendus compte que c'était tous
pareils que c'est les moyens qui change
il ya ceux qui prônent la violence et
ceux qui prônent cette autre violence
encore plus terrible et meurtrière à la
une de leurs shows nos pour les
marocains c'est tous pareils - faut les
combattre et nous les combattrons et ça
ne passera pas quelle a été la réaction
du parti de la justice et du
développement qui est un parti islamique
qui est reconnue et qui participent ou
la vie démocratique du maroc bien sûr
qu'ils les ont témoin qui les ont
condamnés mais lorsque leurs
responsables elle a une de sept présents
vous parliez tout à l'heure
font l'apologie de ces groupuscules
radicaux qui aujourd'hui agissent sur le
terrain ils sont aussi responsables que
c'est treize kamikazes qui sont
marocains des jeunes qui se sont fait
encadrer et manipulés par des personnes
qui auraient pu être celle du pjd
mais le pjd a condamné les attentats et
pourquoi leur intervention n'a pas été
retransmise de la télévision marocaine
sur tvm je ne suis pas la tvm je suis
deuxième chaîne de télévision mais le
fait est que vous n'allez pas dans un
moment comme celui ci où les partis
politiques progressistes de ce pays et
sont nombreux les rejettent leurs 19
fait votre manif tout seul on la fera
pas avec vous on fera la note de notre
côté bon il est tout à fait la réaction
est tout à fait normal
et moi je le dis et je le revendique
je refuse comme ça a été le cas où un sa
tombe responsable de la presse française
un moment donné qu'ils ont décidé
officieusement de banaliser leurs
discours leurs appels au meurtre
ce n'est pas cela la démocratie ce n'est
pas cela le maroc que moi je voudrais je
suis vous proposait finalement c'est
qu'on considère au maroc
le pjd comme en france le front national
est considéré c'est à dire qu'il n'est
pas admis en fait dans le jeu médiatique
votre comparaison est un peu caricatural
mais je vous dirais une chose elle me
convient tout à fait et je crois que si
vous posiez la question de savoir
pourquoi tout d'un coup ils ont 38
députés au parlement je vous dirais
qu'on n'a pas pu venir la vague qui a
été celle de le pen
l'année dernière mais je passerai sur
les détails je dirais que la comparaison
n'est pas malvenu
giles est des copains qui sont tentés
par
l'islamisme maroc ou en france de l'air
malheureusement malheureusement dans nos
quartiers souvent les mêmes de mon
quartier sont pas respectés et un
terroriste c'est quoi enfin j'ai pas la
définition mais je pense que c'est un
peu c'est d'abord un frustré c'est comme
ça qu'on va pas comme ça qu'on recherche
quand un con qu'on méprise et c'est
est-ce que ça doit être profondément
meurtrie je crois pour pouvoir en
arriver là et je sais que ça fait même
de mon quartier donc facilement se
rendre igad et et se retrouve dans des
histoires bizarres parce qu'on n'est
calcule pas si on les écoute pas parce
qu'on a on les rejette en bloc et si
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir aujourd'hui
sans prendre parce qu'on pense parce
qu'à un moment donné on m'a dit tu es un
mec bien quand tu le fons et et c'est
devant ce discours là que j'ai eu envie
de faire mieux et 1 et 2 et de décider
du mieux que je peux de décevoir
personne
mais c'est sûr que que nous en tout cas
dans leurs bottes dans le banlieue comme
comme je le répète souvent non on est en
zone d'éducation prioritaire si on est
en zone d'urbanisation priorité est
ailleurs et comme quand on est quand on
vend des commerces et aux zones franches
qu'elle lancera les appels des zonards
ce que je veux dire c'est difficile et
c'est sûr que quand on trouve le
réconfort dans une mosquée je comprends
pas mais je lis je lui explique en tout
cas c'est c'est des mots que j'ai devant
et qui dit tu es un mec bien continue
lâche pas pour quels domaines et
secteurs d'activité dévolu ça fait
toujours plaisir
c'est vrai qu'au maroc le succès des
islamistes radicaux c'est plus que leurs
prêches encore c'est la façon qu'ils ont
de s'occuper des gens c'est l'accent sur
le terrain ils ont des actions de
solidarité des actions caritatives
y'a que le pjd cas un vrai projet de
société on se demande si les autres
partis politiques qui s'en remet en jeu
démocratique au maroc ont des projets de
société aussi défini que pjd ça c'est
faux c'est faux thierry ces fossés
véhicule est effectivement par syndrome
de publications celles dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure il y en a plusieurs y en
a deux ou trois et c'est aussi ce que
les médias occidentaux souhaitent
retenir
vous le savez très bien on ne parle
jamais des trains qui arrivent à l'heure
on ne parle que de ceux qui sont en
retard c'est une très belle
samira lâche pas le morceau tout le tien
le pjd est un train qui malheureusement
arriver en retard aux attentes nos gènes
auraient leur note juste juste un oui on
attend qu'ils ont c'est vraiment ça elle
n'en attendait la tonne atteint au site
arrête de parler monsieur m'a dit non
j'ai pas mon tir et 15 et que jake
shields alors que la laisser tranquille
ne faut pas l'énerver
mais c'est vrai enfin ils n'ont pas de
projet de société ils n'ont pas de
revendications ils n'ont pas de message
vous savez il joue un peu sur cette
fibre arabo-musulmane attention et nous
les arabes et l'identité et ses joues
sur cette fibre
il en profite très franchement pour mon
pays c'est la première fois c'est pour
ça que j'étais choqué jeudi en début
d'émission que ça m'avait c'est bon sens
et fait mal au coeur de voir dans cet
état là mais mais mais c'est des sharks
est grave mais encore une fois plus
personne n'est à l'abri donc on en parle
aujourd'hui moi vraiment sur le coup
j'étais très choquée et puis finalement
je me suis dit c'est la vie je vais pas
m'arrêter de vivre pour je vais pas
m'arrêter de continuer à aa les n'en est
pas qui c'est c'est si le début pour moi
presque
ouais il n'en est pas quitte pas de la
résistance c'est le début de l'ajout et
j'ai pas pris ça quand tu veux m'aimer
mais c'est le début
c'est le début parce que aujourd'hui je
crois en mon pays ça paye encore
quelqu'un qui est plein de promesses à
diagou tient à tajine makfoul par
exemple je veux et comment sa déchirante
à gérer mais ça l'a déjà dit mon premier
voyage à l'étranger au maroc quand
j'avais 16 ans alors franchement si vous
prive et agile mort foule à cause de
terroristes vous êtes peu
bien secousse marocain et couscous
tunisien alors là il ya du poisson et
même personne la même et tu vois juste
n'avions je voulais profiter de deux il
s'est passé il ya pas longtemps une
chose terrible en algérie et un
tremblement de terre ça a fait 500 morts
des milliers de blessés
on n'a pas de pot bordel de merde c'est
ça qui est en train de me dire on n'a
pas de pot et puis moi j'ai envie
d'adresser un message d'espoir à tous
ces algériens à tous ces marocains qui
s'ouvre à tous ces musulmans qui ont
regardé au maghreb qui qui qui qui qui
sont qui sont dans le lot dans le noir
il faut il ya trop qu'on se dit plutôt
douce et si la douleur tu sais enfin à
la fin de chaque phrase m dulay tout va
bien et j'ai envie de leur dire la lbu
lien on est encore là
alors je lui font bon termine en disant
un mot au sujet du roi du maroc qui
regardent souvent tout le monde en parle
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va tenir bon face à il faut juste
peut-être dire que quand on dit modery
radical machin serra le roi commandeur
des croyants etc
il n'est pas le représentant d'un islam
modéré
il est le représentant de l'islam puis
cours le ceux qui connaissent les livres
qui connaissent le courant et je vous
invite à le faire si vous ne connaissez
pas ce n'est pas cette haine qui se
déversent tous les jours en ce moment
c'est cesser de l'amour c'est de la
tolérance et beaucoup de vérités et
corrompent qu'on donnerait les attentes
hors bien sûr bien sûr
alors lorsqu'on en brigade ce pauvre
gamin et que l'on dit vas-y tu ira au
paradis
eh bien on leur ment on leur dit que
même une femme qui les attend et la saaq
est en même temps un vois moi
franchement je voulais vraiment le
terroriste c'est pas mal fait le calcul
me laisse bercer
merci
bakou
exceptionnel alors au maroc une femme
directrice de l'information d'une chaîne
de télévision
ouais elle tout ce que ça implique au
maroc et c'est pas dedans tu vois c'est
une oeuvre que j'adore ella ella ella
beaucoup de courage et beaucoup de
charisme
ça me rase et m'écoutent je te kiffe